[موسيقى]
انا حماده ملقب في حماده التايلندي كنت
اعمل في اكبر مطعم في قطاع غزه مطعم
التايلندي عدد زملائي كان في المطعم هذا
170 شخص يعني بتحكي على 1700 عئله كانوا
يتعايشوا من المطعم هذا طبعا الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هدموا المطعم بالكامل مش بس
هدموا المطعم وذكرياتنا الحلوه اللي
[موسيقى]
فيه حاولت اني ادبر شويه امكانيات عاديه
في معدات محدوده جدا قدرت اعمل بسطه وعملت
سندوش بسيط حاولت ابسط فيه الناس والناس
تجملت علي وانبسطت وحاولت اساعد الناس
اللي كانت تشوفني ومش مقتدره كمان تشتري
اي ساندويش او اي صح
رزكس
را فنتمنى انه نشوف كل شعبنا هالا هذه
اللي بتستحق الحياه نشوفها باحسن الظروف
وتخلص هال الغم هذا على خير ونشوف احبابنا
اللي احنا فقدنا منهم كتير
ناس
ه